[Music]
in relaxed parenting news submitted by
extra ice that's fine that is the
opposite of literally no ice one cube it
dilutes and it ruins the deal yet you
use it in yo your alcohol drink so then
there's no ice in the ice cube tray you
don't have any I refill the ice cube
tray all the [ __ ] time I will divorce
you over this year semi-free out of all
the things I will divorce you over these
ice cones [ __ ] the irreconcilable
differences if I've ever heard of this
is the fighting table do anything did
you see me doing manic you're at war
over this at all over the ice cube
friends like we're [ __ ] going at it
are you [ __ ] you guys we filled with
sink water yeah yeah we okay yeah you
can't taste the towel or kind of an acid
people yeah we also like eat each
other's mouth yeah she put like she put
it's my PB in her mouth I put her over
down in my mouth yeah I'm pretty much I
guess like it doesn't yeah here is a
look inside the spa that was created for
exhausted parents to smell like
eucalyptus I don't know cuz I don't know
what it feels like to be an exhausting
me neither I casted I'm always [ __ ]
tired Glee is good
yeah you guys are birth control for me
right now yeah you you and Christina and
Dan Barton G oh yeah watching you guys
when we were just a year play yeah how
Bart was basically just spending the
whole time trying to get make sure that
tyga didn't kill himself which he was
trying to do the entire time by the way
dude I think I'm I'm 2 votes against
right now and then I'm just like all
babies are so cute but then I'm like oh
nine months of carrying that in my yeah
it doesn't give me like baby fever when
I see that I just go oh that's awesome
you got one now I get to play with a
baby yeah
- Lee yeah well you guys deal with the
lack of sleep and crazy yeah don't get
me wrong we're not rocking my baby to
sleep
I like 4:00 in the morning I'm like oh
I'm [ __ ] tired and then I open my
eyes like oh she's so cute
and I go do that you know but that's a
biological reaction if you do you would
be like baby go to sleep what became
more apparent to me was why I think our
parents were really strict it's because
if you allow your kid to do whatever
then you're just babysitting them the
whole time versus you say you stay here
or I'll [ __ ] kill you and you know
what they're gonna do then it relieves
your stress that's what I've noticed cuz
like new parents now they don't want to
like put their kids in a box
they don't want to traumatize let's go
ahead do this okay I'll stop which is a
great thing actually but the reason why
out of Peters do the other way didn't
have time for that [ __ ] so it's like hey
stay here you stop making [ __ ] noise
I'll kill you because I'm about to
[ __ ] go crazy
let's see like Bart and you right now
the like you saying like to Leia you do
this or I'll [ __ ] kill you is like
telling a dairy cow not just like to
stop moving
yeah it's like that doesn't and they
don't understand exactly is it's
hopefully within the next couple of
months or years right you think and
understand when do they start
understanding what I feel like a year
well she can understand right now
certainty see what you're saying they
just can't stop themselves understand
some things she can bring me a book but
if you're like she did turn pages if you
like don't move very bad does she listen
uh you know what grandma the other day
was like don't don't get those plugs out
of the socket and she's like you know so
they know and they don't move
if that's your boundary solves yeah
after a few seconds they kind of forget
ATD they're born they're testing your
grandma's hard core she's like I'm gonna
let you figure this out you go ahead and
hold the socket but don't you pull the
plugs out of the socket my [ __ ] sister
would be like
picking the baby up and [ __ ] I like they
sit on the couch like nope don't do that
yeah well you can always enclose your
baby soo you know you put a gate around
them they just walk around in circles in
like a dairy cow nothing I'm saying I
just want my kid to be NOK elliptic for
the first five years
wait is that with a steel [ __ ] no I want
my kid is still [ __ ] for the first five
I'll be dope perfect age to steal get
away when you're an infant it is because
it's so innocent
yeah sorry he took it at the grocery
store this boss called spa Lilla
finest bar Leila sounds good
yeah and it's located in Studio City
here in LA
oh that's like that's where we used to
live I used to run past there but it
used to be called something else used to
be called like spoiled spoiled brats
yeah so this spot is specifically
designed like for parents that is so la
we used to live on Tujunga we did we
live with a great egos like all you
blocks from there really
yeah there was always tourists driving
by taking pictures of Brady Bunch house
somebody like right there and it was a
Pokemon stop when Polk guhmungo was like
for three days when pokemons always like
this [ __ ] yeah but not to the master oh
I so picture this being a la thing where
the moms are like stay-at-home moms but
then they're still [ __ ] so stressed
out and they have to do this thing and
like [ __ ] yeah I'm not knocking down how
busy it is ya know mom's pal
whoa whoa
all I'm saying is most moms and like our
moms and they had to go through so much
[ __ ] more and they never they never
had like stuff like this yeah so you
should be happy that you live in today's
time that's what I always say yeah I'm
always like yeah I'm so loving that I
live in the future I'm like you're so
lucky to be in the now are you kidding
me bro yeah yeah so here's more photos
this is like the kid area so they have
nannies and they have to be you know
like fully certified like trust and out
like trust sir how do you relax with
your kid next door screaming their
[ __ ] head off that's a Jew that's
what a lot of people say right so this
room soundproof hell yeah oh [ __ ]
there's also a we lock them up mock over
they can't breathe in there there's a
window where you could see inside and
you can like check in on your kids good
interrogation this you just put it right
here [ __ ] my kids you know what it is to
is like a lot of people are so far away
from family and people that can help and
it's just everyone so like separated
yeah and it's either single moms or a
single parent or like small little like
my parents I mean your situation my
parents it's like that's how my parents
were yo how the [ __ ] are we gonna
survive dude i legit don't know how my
sister does it without my folks because
my like she just had another baby but
I'm saying yeah she just had another
baby last month yeah congrats thank you
both of you aunts and uncles again we
did a lot of work he's a redhead by the
way so it's not that don't congratulate
on a [ __ ] soulless child yeah exact
thank you this is by the way my second
redheaded nephew so I'm ready to give up
I like redheads kids yeah that's nice
but but they got fire hair I used to
want to have red hair when I was younger
cuz Ariel but without my parents they
could not do it because they both work
like it's it I don't know how we're
gonna do it living in LA with everyone
so spread out higher bring them here
like I deal with Leah I'm gonna fly my
parents out here they're gonna live here
and they're gonna take care of my kids
really my mom's too old for this [ __ ]
you
our reference I mean without the
grandparent factor it's really hard cuz
even my parents they had my dad's
parents and so they would take care of
us on the weekends at least you know and
during the weekdays we will switch off
with our aunts or do you know when you
have like that family factor to come in
and help but without that I mean running
a business doing like 90 hours a week
how the [ __ ] would have that could
possible and so you have to pay for that
help and then it's always weird yeah
the nanny's closer to the camp being to
pay off the babies that are a lot of
people in their situation like the way
that they where they work they don't get
paid enough so then they have to pay for
the sitter it doesn't - whoa not work
that's why I was working on my parents
tour the whole time yeah cuz they had a
you know what I'm gonna move to like a
very I'm gonna save up money and I'm
gonna move to like somewhere that has
nothing and I'm just gonna pop out so
many kids out of the word and your sugar
cane farm he's gonna do all the work
yeah yeah I'm gonna come into mango
trees and then they're gonna grow out of
mango trees little pods that sounds like
a like a [ __ ] like Indian folklore
did you like the meat in the mango
you're a sweet mango baby yeah yeah so
this spot here they're saying that they
have like services for like pregnant or
postpartum moms or just anyone and that
they have this requirement where every
two hours you have to check in on your
kids so it's not like you just leave
them there forever and then they also
have this map room where for 25 minutes
you can pay $40 and enjoy a nap what the
[ __ ] what if you can't all sleep in that
amount of time I know no you will you
will as an exhausted parent exactly it's
like that's the whole thing here is for
exhausted parents and then so the first
child you take it in as free as long as
you're getting a spa service and then
each additional kid is $6 that's not bad
yeah and then they also have like a
whole bunch of activities activities for
the kids
so then some parents they have like you
know guilt that they're treating
themselves and then their kids are just
being taken care of so they also have
like yoga classes or art classes or in
music classes for the kids to do while
you're getting your spa treatment dude
this is so sad yeah thank you because
like that
is how disconnected we are as humans to
our family members to our friends and
how overworked we are because if you
think about it right like like one so
like it's like a mom's it's like it's
whether you're single mom or just a
stay-at-home mom right
like the whole damn day dad is out
working or like you can't go to sleep
you can't do whatever and then you don't
have family members you can rely on
there's no breaks you're 24/7 with this
kid
we're like in other cultures and
societies it's like you can you take a
shower take care of good take a nap yeah
and then you have like grandma and
aunties and everyone else kind of like
you kind of get a break and then it just
moves around like that yeah well this is
for the people without options cuz like
my sister has family like there's family
around it's just for people who are kind
of [ __ ] you know what you do you don't
have options like me I'm a part-time dad
so there's this play method I have in my
living room and I'll put her there to
play and I let her be and I'm laying on
that mat just like this I'm paying
attention you just walking around
playing nice so safer padded yeah it's
all padded you know and then once she
walks away I got all the way I gotta go
get her but that's how I get my rest on
that play mat well you know what did you
fall asleep it's happened where I'm like
oh [ __ ] you know but I just try not a
good way the spa services cost oh yeah
we might just go there just to rub it in
that we don't have any kids puppy is
that the same thing you you have bubbies
and kids just [ __ ] playing around
loving yeah so they get bit it's like I
got a gecko can I get a break for my
gecko you guys take care of him please
well it depends what you want so like
can we put husband's in there hey wait a
second hey don't be a great idea is like
us uh kind of like a man cave she cave
kind of thing where you go together and
you split and then like the kind of like
the she caves though mm-hmm they're very
calming in the West yeah you could do
some she caves and men can see the spa
stuff yeah well they put like eucalyptus
yeah eucalyptus
yeah they look good nails and waxing I
don't even know how exhausted parents
can afford that [ __ ] because they're
mostly unemployed like the real parents
that need it yeah they're [ __ ]
unemployed you're struggling is it
really I mean the way I see it it's like
this is a studio system
I understand what you're saying cause
it's like if you can afford this luxury
that you should be able to afford a
nanny do they're wearing Lululemon's
they're you know give me a break
that's what I was trying to point out
like not the single mom thing but it's
like these people are so like stressed
out yeah cuz I know the type of people
that are going they don't have a feed
their own child
so like I'm sorry I have to go shopping
for shoes for my spin class so stressed
out
[Music]